[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance le bonheur et
le plaisir de recevoir un versailles et
en illinois qui s'appelle alain baraton
à la marathon bonjour bonjour vous allez
bien très bien et très heureux d'être
avec vous ce temps là là quelle joie
alors merci d'être venus jusqu'ici vous
êtes tout le sel jardinier en chef du
domaine national de versailles
vous êtes chroniqueur sur france inter
aussi voilà les samedis dimanches la
main verte
à l'aube de la télévision privée chéri
venir je redémarre à la rentrée j'en
suis très heureux aux côtés de thomas et
bien oui et oui c'est reparti et
emprunter maya elle va présenter
télématin le vendredi samedi dimanche là
mais je suis très heureux donc vous êtes
là à jour par semaine
oui l'émission va peut-être changer de
formule me le suis toujours
toujours présent et très heureux des
machines j'imagine et alors vous êtes
aussi surtout écrivain vous en êtes à
votre quasi vingtième ouvrage imaginé
pour à peu près une petite vingtaine
d'années je n'ai jamais écrire je n'ai
pas d'hésitation ses généreuses à le
transmettre
je t'annonce souffert de cette
profession qui n'était pas très
valorisante
quand j'étais gamin que l'idée
qu'aujourd'hui je puisse à me
transmettre un savoir faire rêver de
temps en temps ce qui comme moi aiment
récrire pour moi est un véritable
bonheur mais écoutez c'est réussi ça se
sent alors vous êtes ici parce que vient
de sortir le dictionnaire amoureux des
arbres chez plon alors vous aviez déjà
écrit et le dictionnaire amoureux des
jardins vous aviez aussi écrit en 2013
chez actes sud une sorte de pamphlet la
haine des arbres n'est pas une fatalité
un coup de colère un coin de coups de
colère contre tous ces arbres que l'on
abat pour des motifs chieuse souvent au
futile
hélas ces peuples que lost un coude à un
peu un coup de foudre cours habituels
oui mais menomena mais de plaisanter par
millions
mais on y est on est on est dans le coup
de foudre je suis tombé amoureux des
arbres
quand je vois un arbre qui a 200 300 400
en vain davantage je suis admiratif je
ne peux m'empêcher de le toucher de
regarder et de l'aimer et de l'aimer et
à l'ordre donc comment avez vous abordé
donc ce nouveau dictionnaire amoureux
des arbres allaient beaucoup de
difficultés et je remercie mon éditeur
d'avoir eu la patience d'attendre
j'aurais dû rendre cet ouvrage il ya
plusieurs années déjà années et ont
gagné jauge de quatre ans de retard
quand je n'ai pas mis vingt ans pour
l'écrire ne mentons pas mais je voulais
vraiment que ce soit moi que comment
dire que je puisse exprimer mon
véritable ressentais un dictionnaire
amoureux c'est pas un guide c'est pas un
inventaire c'est une expression
sentimentale pour un végétal ou un ou
une personne qui tourne entre chômage et
al j'ai voulu prendre mon temps j'ai
voulu faire de jolis textes eux j'ai
voulu écrire avec mon coeur j'ai pas
voulu en piles et mettre le les lettres
les unes après les autres pour faire de
la page d'un an c'est vraiment des
textes choisis je fais une sélection
d'auteurs qui ont cure ont écrit de
manière merveilleuse sur les âmes des
poètes des citations
j'ai voulu parler de personnages
extraordinaires walking buffalo un chef
amérindien qui parlait avec les arbres
je parle de jeanne bar est incroyable
que jeanne barré ne soit pas davantage
connue mais oui mais grâce à vous elle
est maintenant moi je l'espère c'est la
première fois qu'on raconte en deux mots
ton histoire cette première femme qui a
fait le tour du monde
tu va accompagner un botaniste du nom de
commerciaux et en il convient quand on
est au xviiie siècle
oui on est soumis ont détruit 16 pour
être exact je la trouve extraordinaire
et cette femme veut absolument a compris
et commerçons qui est un des plus grand
botaniste et pour être acceptée sur un
bateau elle se déguise en homme
elle sera bien entendu rapidement
identifié mais contrairement à ce que
l'on pourrait croire elle ne sera pas
condamné
elle va devenir une sorte de petit un
peu la chouchou des membres d'équipage
et quand elle reviendra en france elle
sera remercié par le 1016 et leur même
une pension à vie pour le travail
accompli mais il est vrai et c'est mon
regret à cette femme dont il y en a très
très bon je parle de voguer remercier
leur instit les hommes ne les mettez pas
en valeur
combien de grand botaniste avait des
femmes derrière elle pour justement
écrire ce qu'ils ont fait mais on les
laisser dans l'ombre
voilà donc garé ma taille je sois là je
voulais être prononcées sont donc pas
évident c'est là une femme qui a eu le
prix nobel prix nobel de la paix la paix
cette femme en afrique a fait planter
des millions d'arbres et cette femme
aimait tellement les arbres que par
testament
elle est décédée il ya quelques années
elle avait exigé de ne pas être enterré
dans un cercueil pour ne pas qu'on coupe
pour alan armes dans du bambou
bah oui parce que quand on y découvre
tout c'est que l'on coupons pour les saf
et ça me rappelle cette citation qui est
dans le vrai
que trouve merveilleuse de pierre doris
c'est beau un arbre dans un cimetière
on dirait un cercueil qui pousse alors
c'est un peu dur mais c'est drôle
voilà et alors donc ça c'était votre
fils rouges en fait donc on découvre moi
je trouve à travers ce livre votre part
dan team tout de même pas ce que vous
nous racontez bain un peu comme dans le
permis là de ma mère on vous découvre
jeune homme vous racontez votre histoire
à travers ces mots vous êtes arrivé très
jeune au château dont caissier un petit
job d'été et après vous avez franchi les
étapes que l'on connaît et et on vous
sent comment dire tellement amoureux des
jolies histoires des mots de
l'étymologie g a besoin cadets et non
d'art que vous citez juste pour la
beauté du nom à chanceaux liquidambar ce
septième jeu et liquidambar zi sa sève
étaient employés par les indiens
d'amérique centrale et du sud
donc il y avait dans ce végétal du
liquide en bas sur 510 net et vous
parlez d'intimité on a tous je crois une
histoire d'amour avec un arbre vous avez
peut-être vous même eu un grand père qui
a planté un arbre le grand père est
parti il ya longtemps mais l'arbre lui
est resté peut-être ne répondait pas ce
sera discret avez vous échangé à premier
baiser sous un arbre et cet arbre vit
toujours et quand vous passez à côté de
lui vous pensez à vos premières amours
et une relation très forte entre l'homme
la femme et le et l'arbre et j'ai voulu
en fait en parler je voulais surtout
rappeler que derrière un arbre
il ya toujours une histoire dérisoire
mais extraordinaire des histoires entre
les hommes et l'environnement les
animaux les peler les insectes
il ya des histoires grande
je voudrais juste une que j'adore
l'acacia les fourmis et l'éléphant nous
la raconter cette belle histoire
c'est la question qui vit dans la savane
il produit des épines creuse qui
permettent aux fourmis de venir se
réfugier et de trouver du nectar et
l'acacia et la fourmi vivent ainsi en
bonne harmonie depuis 2002 des
millénaires et s'il y a des fourmis dans
l'acacia c'est pour permettre aux
éléphants d'être tenus à distance car il
ya les éléphants qu'elle veut dire
manger les feuilles si on le laisse
faire un pachyderme
en quelques jours il n'y aura plus
d'acacia lors d une sorte d'harmonie
l'acacia l'éléphant et les fourmis qui
quand il ya trop d'éléphants rentrer
dans les trompes hic les pachydermes
pour leur rappeler qu'ils s'éloignent et
des personnes qui n'ont pas une grande
compétence en matière d'environnement
ont voulu protéger les acacias pour que
les éléphants ne viennent plus du tout
ils ont mis des barbelés tout autour
au bout de quelques années l'acacia n'a
plus besoin de fourmies il n'a donc plus
besoin de les héberger
il supprime ses épines les fourmis ne
viennent plus tous les autres insectes
arrive et on mangeait l'acacia en
quelques temps seulement les éléphants
le pouls de quoi manger
les insectes ont tout dévoré voilà la
peine qui sincèrement la bêtise humaine
mais l'acacia l'éléphant et et la folie
ce serait une petite angie l'histoire
voilà on a toujours besoin voilà ayons
vous fait la part belle justement au
poète a souvent aux fables de la
fontaine d'ailleurs vous nous donnez un
florilège ce moment délicieux de tout ce
qui touche aux arbres par par le prisme
de la poésie et moi je pensais et notre
histoire des idées fausses par exemple
hier on considère toujours comme un
parasite
c'est amusant c'était amusant t il ya 2
et défaut dans le métier qui est le mien
la taupe
je n'en parle pas parce qu'elle n'a rien
à voir avec les arbres mais la taupe est
réputé hémophiles elle ne l'a jamais
jamais été donc mettre des tessons de
bouteilles dans une guérite obsédé jab
est inutile dangereux pour vous mais ça
ne sert à rien et puis le lierre le
lierre vie avec l'arbre une histoire
d'amour le viera besoin d'un tronc pour
l'emmener vers soleil quand il est là le
soleil ils peuvent fructifier pour ça
que le lire foutry fier en hiver quand
les arbres ont perdu leurs feuilles et
le lièvre le lierre ne va repos
un arbre que lorsque celui ci sera
dépérissants en un mot il pratique soit
là mais une sorte de thann asie mais
c'était pas l'arbre qui va le lierre qui
va étouffer l'arbre c'est parce que
l'armée est en train de mourir que le
liait à brel ses filles france
il ya donc une histoire d'âme mais bien
sûr bien sûr c'est une manière de
favoriser sa chute sa décomposition
l'amendement de la terre et permettre à
de jeunes plants de mieux redémarrer et
dans les forêts vous ne verrez jamais
jamais un lierre envers un arbre sain
donc nous résumons quand un arbre est
malade et qu'il adule hier c'est parce
qu'il est malade qu'il adule y est et
c'est pas parce que la du levier acculé
malades
ok je vais pas bien alors bon vous vous
révoltez parce que vous trouvez qu'on
abat les arbres vous le dit d'ailleurs
comme d'habitude avec beaucoup de franc
parler haut et fort les arbres ne sont
pas assez protégés en france une option
peu macho c'est une honte et serait
grand temps que ceux qui nous dirigent
il serait grand temps que toutes les
associations enfin l association dont
vous parlez dont vous avez signé la
charte qui s'appelle arbres avec un elle
est merveilleuse
c'est une association dirigée par
georges petermann qui a pour objet de
répertorier de de soigner c'est possible
et est de protéger les arbres
remarquables charte
voilà ça s'est également élevée relève
qu'il travaille au sein d'un conseil
régional c'est donc cet homme et georges
feterman qui ont eu envie
l'idée géniale de créer la charte des
droits de l'arbre charte à laquelle je
je contribue bien tandis que je signe
mes relais des dès demain et cette
charte permettrait alors enfin d'avoir
une reconnaissance officielle il est
scandaleux aujourd'hui je dis bien
scandaleux que l'on puisse en toute
impunité couper des arbres pions
plusieurs siècles d'histoire car un
arbre ce n'est pas qu'un morceau de bois
ce n'est pas plus quelques foyers de la
serre c'est un morceau de notre histoire
c'est un c c'est le nôtre passé ce sont
des monuments historiques
alors qu'est ce qui pousse certains
hommes donc à abattre assassiner des
termes ascap à une sorte de jouissance
son espèce de désir de montrer sa
puissance m'abuse d'avoir un complexe
d'infériorité
je découpe et la bêtise montrer qu'on
est plutôt crois qu'on est supérieure à
la nature le non tenues
un peu comme ceux qui dans leur viseur
auront un éléphant ils vous diront quand
l'option c'est pour permettre aux
comment dire une meilleure gestion de la
faune sauvage at il été si voilà mais
tous et dès que du pipeau comme on dit
vulgairement un vote un art par exemple
très ancien est dangereux quand ils
menacent de tomber
la première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
voir si l'on ne peut pas faire une mise
à distance pour éviter qu'il ne tombe
sur quelqu'un et on le comprend
peut-être peut-on empêcher le public
d'approcher peut-on peut-être comme le
chêne d'allouville le soutenir et ne le
coupent et que finalement c'est a besoin
vraiment de le faire moi j'ai connu
alors vous avez connu j'imagine des cas
semblables à versailles oui bien sûr
mais nous a versé de coupon les armes
quand il faut le faire donc pas par
plaisir
vous avez déjà souvenez-vous le chêne de
manteaux n'être qu'une fois qu'il était
mort a même été exposé devant le petit
trianon pour ça vous montre
l'attachement que nous avons aussi mais
il est évident que quand un arbre dans
une cour d'école menace de tomber bien
sûr qu'il faut le couper
bien entendu il ne faut pas non plus
extrémistes mais dans certains cas comme
ce fut le cas dans une commune des
vosges et quelques années
couper un arbre vieux de 450 ans parce
qu'on va abriter le temps d'un week-end
seulement l'instant tamponneuses
on est donc on est un criminel c'est la
réaliser vous n'avez pas idée s'est pas
aidé de tous ces hommes qui ont été
coupés pour satisfaire quelques délires
de quelques architectes se voit là pour
l'argent ou la bêtise mais dans ce livre
par contre je n'en parle pas non parce
que je voulais parler de bonheur je veux
parler d'amour voilà donc c'est ça ce
dont je vous remercie parce que il ya
l'amour sans votre amour des arts on
sent votre amour des mots que du bonheur
que des histoires magnifiques
à lire absolument à raconter le soir à
la veillée aux enfants pourquoi serait
bien ce qu'ont repris vie oui je sors la
cgt oui c'est ça la cheminée poutine
était sur la plage sur la plage et
raconter ses histoires
mais fait nouveau livre pour enfants
sous l'eau mais pourquoi pas avec des
jeux des histoires comme l'acacia
premier éléphant
mais bien sûr qu'en appelant un grand
merci en tout cas ce qui est un vrai
bonheur un vrai plaisir je pense
toujours à tourner à le lire à passer un
bon été
et puis à très vite pour un nouveau
livre
à bientôt oui a très vite merci à la
marathon merci à tous de nouveau à
savoir cloud par don de nous avoir
suivis
[Musique]